hi i'm jennifer hudson and this is the
wired auto complete interview
oh have i ever googled myself before you
want me to answer that
what is jennifer hudson what does that
mean what is jennifer hudson
what is jennifer hudson's vocal range
my vocal range is first soprano that is
my vocal range that's as far as i know
but yes but i could send you alto 10 up
bass and i call that the hudson nets
okay so whatever you need me to sing i
can hold down the whole soprano section
the church choir
what you need next slide
uh
what was jennifer hudson
my nails along give me a second
first song
i wonder what google got to say about
that jennifer hudson's first song would
be spotlight
jennifer hudson's the actress first song
would be
and i'm telling you slash i love you i
do but i love you i do is my very first
original song
what did jennifer hudson
win an oscar for
i won an oscar for dream girls my first
film as effie white and dreamgirls the
musical and i was also or my song
jennifer hudson's first song was
nominated for an oscar which was i love
you i do but for drink girls
what did jennifer hudson hold on hold on
name her dog okay guys y'all know i had
two dogs
i got to give you a story real quick
y'all got time okay i got a dog that
christmas before i won the oscar and i
named the dog oscar and then i want to
oscar so then i said child oscar need a
girlfriend so i got a dog and that
summer and i named her grammy and guess
what
cha i want a grammy
that winner that rolled around and then
oscar grammy had a baby and guess what
we might be dream girl
she's still here but oscar and grammy
have gone on miss them dearly so that
means i need a new oscar and i need a
new grammy what is jennifer hudson
pandemic hobby
oh
i got so many pandemic hobbies as if you
did not know i am a two-way artist so i
also draw as well as sing the singing
comes from my grandmother and the
drawing comes from my mother i spray
paint draw on
everything i can i didn't spray painted
the toilets to the bikes
my bentley and everything purple is my
favorite color
one of my toilets is pink and purple
i'm having a bike specially spray
painted by a professional this time to
get it right
because i just oh i spray painted the
piano too they like jennifer please stop
spray painting things but it's like it's
my house i can do what i want and my
stuff i work hard for my money okay what
does jennifer hudson
tom jones
is the love of my life
i love tom jones to be able to sit with
him sit next to him and then sing with
him
and then to listen to his stories like
he knew every legend from frank sinatra
to aretha and then to password and i get
to sit with him and i get to sing with
him y'all know he the original done
right what we got here all right
what oh who is jennifer
who is jennifer hudson playing aretha
franklin yes i'm playing
the queen of soul miss aretha franklin
which was a dream of mine and also her
request for me to play her which is
a dream come true but yet it's the
scariest thing ever it's like
aretha has taken over my life and i just
want to make her proud as best as i can
to know someone as powerful
as aretha franklin who's
known for her voice had to find her own
personal voice her own expression her
own way and that inspired me i know we
all have a respect for aretha but by the
time we get to the end of the film i
wanted them to have a newfound respect
for miss franklin which i do as well you
see my necklace watch off all right who
is
jennifer hudson hold on these nails
y'all trying to tell me i'm playing
hercules
how cutely
y'all listen close all my dream girls
cast members this is a fun fact have
been in disney films anika beyonce
jamie eddie has done everything where's
my disney bro
but i was calliope the head muse on a
disney cruise ship so that means i'm
ready for my part we are the muses
goddesses are the arts and proclaimers
of heroes hope with the gladden
gladiators hercules
that was me calliope so i'm ready just
roll the camera you ain't got to send a
script i don't need the music i'm ready
to shoot so i'll just wait for your call
thank you okay who is jeffrey oh and
also a fun fact they took as a acting
credit my experience on a cruise ship
for me to be in dreamgirls
who is jennifer hudson's dad and cindy
rex i
definitely don't know who
these are the questions y'all asked okay
who is jennifer hud's character in drink
girls my character is dream girls
it's effie white
cup no let me get my key right cuz
i ain't saying this is so long
cause this time that's not right cause
she i was so hot cause this time
f.b.i
is gonna
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh who is the character i need to read
the rest of the question who is jennifer
hudson character and dream girls based
on i think your film is loosely based on
the supremes florence ballard
at least that's you know who i studied
for
effie
and drink girls
how jennifer hudson
is using these nails how is
how is jennifer hud
how is it
how am i doing i am doing so good i am
blessed i am grateful i'm happy to be
here
you know what this
to me i would have thought would have
been the number one question because
this is the number one thing i get
everywhere i go the first thing people
say is i had no idea you were that tall
fun fact i am the tallest dream girl i'm
the youngest string girl but the tallest
dream girl i am 5
without a heel
supermodel with the hill okay write it
down also that is why in dreamgirls
effie is in flats because i would have
towered jamie in heels
jamie foxx that is
one of my absolute favorites
how to sing how to sing like jennifer
jennifer don't even know i don't think
there's an answer to that
sing from the heart
sing with joy sing because you want to
because most of all is it's an
expression because it's your joy it's
your expression it's your feeling and as
long as you go from there it can never
be wrong sing from your heart as aretha
would say
fill it
and i will be there to cheer you on
don't you worry
how many grammys
do i have this is fun because
most don't know i have
a grammy for my first album and then i
have a grammy for color purple but i
also have an honorary grammy as well so
would that be two and a half or three
you tell me okay oh i see you ain't
finished the question oh yeah well how
many grammys do i have
okay
can jennifer hudson can jennifer hudson
i knew that was what that was gonna say
okay listen i can hear by ear
a little bit everybody in my family can
my son can he gets up plays the piano a
host of cousins a little bit i could
hear by ear we were born that way but i
also took piano lessons to channel
aretha franklin that much more as an
actor i felt it was important to do that
if i was going to embody a character
like aretha who piano playing was a huge
part of so i felt it was my duty so yes
i mean i ain't no aretha don't don't
don't you think that for one second but
i could peck she played
can jennifer hudson sing whistle notes
okay oh this is another good one when i
was in high school i could do the entire
piano like the whole piano and the kids
should be like she's still going but
when i went away to college
the climbing of the weather
i couldn't even speak by the time i came
back which is why i left college and
then i was able to gain my voice back
and i changed my singing approach so
most notes i hit full voice versus head
tone
which reshapes the instrument i say i
wish so like i could whistle for you
right and then but everyone says my
whistle sounds like singing so they
consider it the that i do whistle notes
but according to the j hud production
standards no i do not do whistles but i
can sing probably the highest notes on
the piano in full voice go find somebody
who can do that and then we can talk
okay
can jennifer hudson
hold on get this off can i dance if you
pay me enough yes i danced on a disney
cruise ship cause calliope is nothing
but choreography the muses is all
choreography all day i have to choose
between singing and dancing baby i ain't
got time for no steps i need to sing you
this song i gotta use my superpower and
i just move my knee in my shoulders so
when y'all see that that's all you're
gonna get
is jennifer hudson a vegan
i'm gonna tell you all i eat is chicken
turkey and fish now you tell me what i
am
is jennifer hudson an egot according to
the j hood production center no i do not
i have grammys obviously the oscar but i
have a ring that says ego so when i get
an emmy i would i don't have an ego
which stands for amy grammy oscar
although fun fact i have been a part of
so many different things that has won
emmy's but i personally
don't consider it as my own or a a
legitimate win because
it's not according to my standards
but one day it'll come
until until then i'll be content with my
what i got
go
grammy
and oscar
okay
uh
is jennifer hudson the best singer how
are you going to actually hustle if she
the best thing y'all trying to set me up
nope that's a trick question but if you
think i am thank you so much i truly
appreciate it is jennifer hudson if am i
left-handed no i'm right-handed i guess
that's the only answer to that
is jennifer hudson
is jennifer hudson and whitney houston
related i love this question
i don't know
what is funny is when i go out people
easily call me jennifer houston or
holiday which is totally fine with me
we're in the same family i guess you
could say peter's hair
if you pay me enough money remember that
has jennifer hudson
you know jennifer get on my nerves
google that i'll be like oh my god
jennifer
been on broadway yes i have been on
broadway i was on broadway doing color
purple that was my broadway debut will i
go back
know about that okay
gender does jennifer hudson sing because
jennifer has the sake of respect yes i
do and i sing live and respect almost
every song other than the radio records
that's what you're in film those are
recorded like radio records but anything
that was done live in her life i did
live right there in the film so i'm
literally acting and singing
at the same time does jennifer hudson
live in the uk i love the uk that is
like my second home
oh my god i miss it so much i can't wait
to return do i currently live there no
but will i be back yes i will because i
love the uk and my uk family i miss
y'all but i had to come home and do this
does jennifer hudson
do i have a kid oh
little david he is the sweetest little
baby in the whole wide world yes i do my
little munchkin he'll kill me if i call
him unction so i'm gonna call him what
he wants to be called d.o.j he's now
11 almost 12 years old
and it's coming up and he was actually
with me the last time i heard from miss
franklin he said mama it's that aretha
franklin on the phones i guess it is and
the last thing we did was talk about him
cooking and i sent her videos of him
cooking because she loved cooking and he
did he does as well
okay my nails don't want to let me do
this
okay why does jennifer hudson throw
shoes
guys
it is the biggest compliment okay if i
throw a shoe at you you must have
touched my soul
it is a compliment as will i am saying
it's the soul get it the soul on the
shoe so i guess that's where it comes
from but music moves me in a special way
and it moves my shoes off my feet that
you may catch and i've had people throw
shoes at me
actually it was the barry manilow
audition i auditioned for him and the
judges who were auditioning me by the
time i finished they threw everything
they had off the table at me and i was
like oh so
it's an expression of love
thank you so much
i think you guys had some interesting
questions
i didn't know you want to know those
things about me
did i talk too much